more recent studies are actually showing
in fact caffeine doesn't seem to be
particularly harmful when it comes to
long-term cardiovascular risk
when you look at coffee and caffeinated
tea intake as a whole they actually
have some protective effects on a
variety of long-term health outcomes
when consumed in what most people would
consider a moderate
intake range so if you're drinking the
caffeine equivalent of
one to like maybe five possibly six
cups of coffee a day you actually see a
lot of
risk reductions when it comes to a lot
of long-term health outcomes and
mortality there
once you start getting beyond that five
or six cup a day range
those protective effects seem to become
a little bit less apparent
and my guess would be that at that point
you're also dealing with
other risk factors that you may not be
accounting for in the model
because because like dude as as someone
who really likes
caffeine the only time i personally
would be consuming
six or more cups a day is like if i'm
stressed out of my mind and super sleep
deprived
like there's there's no other reason
that i would consume that much and i'm
someone who loves
caffeine so yeah so that kind of makes
me think that at that end like
you know maybe there's some other [ __ ]
going on that you're not accounting for
yeah so now one caveat to that
there's a paper that said if you are
a fast caffeine metabolizer uh you're
probably fine
when it comes to coffee and caffeine
intake with cardiovascular risk
but if you're genetically a slow
caffeine metabolizer
you actually might have an increased
risk when it comes to
negative cardiovascular outcomes long
term
however i believe a more recent paper
failed to replicate that particular
finding i think there was a paper within
the last year
yeah that that retested that finding and
said
from our from our results that doesn't
really seem to be the case
so um that is still kind of
up in the air when it comes to
determining exactly how we use
the information we have about caffeine
genotype
and how that relates to not just
long-term health
outcomes but even the performance
effects of caffeine there's some
research saying that your
your genotype for the cyp1a2 gene
might influence a whole variety of
outcomes when it comes to your
caffeine responses